ah yes oh [ __ ] man those are getting me
hands hands down worse newscasts of all
time let's look at this here the world
of inflation
guys you probably noticed is that a good
thing or or not a good thing inflation
uh
what
I'm sorry the question again Dave
is is inflation in our world a good
thing or not a good thing it depends
upon what the topic is what are we
talking about generally inflation if you
have an inflatable boat you
right oh but uh generally inflation
not economic something good come to mind
for me yeah yeah I mean well let me who
said yeah there right about if you say
good you're right because this is the
world
Inflatables give ourselves a nice sign
of Applause everybody dude
man just take the baby what kind of fun
do you think
he's still in front of an inflatable fun
house dude good so when inflation so if
you if you think of the word inflation
what comes to mind and then the other
guy well it all depends well yeah it all
depends yeah but if you're talking about
is inflation in is inflation a good
thing or a bad thing are you talking
about inflating a boat yeah
would you can economically so anyway I'm
standing here in front just so much fun
lots of fun that's that's a good kind
this guy's getting so fired it's
unbelievable I can't
um helping just helping everybody oh my
God this guy dude give yourselves a nice
round of applause everybody no no go
back go back is that a good thing or or
not a good thing inflation
waiting so long I'm sorry the question
again Dave
just knows it's unraveling right now in
our world but still owning it or not a
good thing it depends upon what the
title is no see that guy literally that
guy's a dick he hates the other guy and
knows it's failing when he's just like
you
right right oh but uh generally when you
hear the word inflation
not economic something good come to mind
yeah yeah God
well let me tell you that you're right
about if you say good you're right
because this is the world of Inflatables
give yourselves a nice round of applause
everybody
here today
um
what kind of fun do you think you're
gonna have today
um
that's a good kind oh what kind of fun
are you gonna have lots of fun that's a
good kind
um helping just helping everybody what
what does this lady mean
what is that so fun that's a that's a
good kind just put the microphone in the
office
face dude without asking helping just
helping everybody
I didn't hear the question oh what kind
of fun do you think you can find here
today what what is the question there
dude
like
all kinds all kinds of fun oh she didn't
say [ __ ] and he just
I wish I wish I was there I've never
I've never wished I was at a place more
than this time this is all kinds all
kinds of fun this guy's getting fired at
they fired him already like in his
earpiece of art bouncing fun yeah I
think so because nobody said bouncing
dude this is a place where kids and
families can come and kind of bounce
around but you need
something and I'm going to have everyone
do it like a magic chant
um all right you guys ready
because when we're talking Inflatables
you need something that's been inflated
are you guys ready
all right here we go uh repeat after me
Abracadabra one two three
now it's time to see what we see
what other thing came out oh my goodness
early dude yeah
just
[ __ ]
train wreck dude I mean this guy came
out so early dude I cannot wait to send
this to all my friends bro this is
unbelievable man
how's everybody doing my name is Mr
wacky welcome to the inflatable run give
me Mr wacky a nice round of applause
Mr wacky this is uh this is an honor
first of all well thank you uh we are
local San Diego so proud to be here
everybody on this wonderful beautiful
Saturday morning welcome Sandy here you
go yeah good morning you guys
[Applause]
this is so much fun here first of all I
mean dude I've never seen something that
looks less fun I can't even believe that
they showed a little bit past the
inflatable thing and there was just like
open parking spaces and it's so dude
nobody's even saying [ __ ] 5K but not
really it's it's longer than a 5k right
well yes each
a one mile lap as many times as they
want we're out here trying to get
families off the couch we're a
family-owned business throwing events
for families in San Diego so we're
really excited to be here we have all
kinds of attractions behind us and of
course that families can run as many
times as they want with inflatables on
them yeah this is great you guys now
does that mean that everybody here
becomes an inflatable today hey wait do
they want to be Inflatables today do you
guys want to be inflatable
yeah absolutely let me see everybody do
their Mr wacky then all right
[Music]
oh my God even the big Levesque is doing
the Mr wacky right now uh yeah you guys
I mean you know asking them if they
wanted to be an inflatable dude that one
was so incredible
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]